Salut, aujourd'hui pour ce jour des astuces, on va apprendre à gagner un peu d'argent.
Enfin une astuce qu'elle est bien.
Tous les mercredis, depuis ce premier Janvier, je vous donne une astuce en rapport avec le mentalisme
pour faire quelque chose qui est en dehors du mentalisme.
Et l'été approchant, je me suis dit: " je vais regarder dans analytics,
quel est la plus grande tranche d'âge qui regarde mes vidéos :
on va dire grosso modo entre 18 et 35 ans.
J'ai additionné cette donnée au fait qu'on allait bientôt être l'été
et que beaucoup d'entre vous allez sûrement travailler dans la restauration, comme serveur,
qui est le job qu'on fait le plus facilement.
Preuve en est que j'ai fait ce job moi aussi !
C'est pourquoi je vais vous livrer mes 5 meilleures astuces
pour avoir des pourboires.
La première astuce consiste à faire travailler votre mémoire.
Ca tombe bien j'ai fait une playlist sur la mémoire !
Vous devriez y trouver à l'intérieur des astuces
qui vont vous permettre de retenir plus facilement qui prend quoi
en fonction de la position de la table.
Évitez de noter avec un carnet mais retenez plutôt qui prend quoi
et juste avant de quitter la table après la prise de la commande, répétez toute la commande entièrement en désignant les personnes.
Ça va instaurer une vraie relation de confiance entre les gens qui viennent de commander et vous
puisque vous avez retenu, vous êtes capable de le répéter donc ils sont complètement rassurés et vous avez re-désigné qui prenait quoi.
Ca va maquer un peu plus la table qu'une prise de commandes au bloc-notes.
La table, où mangent les clients, c'est une espèce de bulle.
Une fois on avait parlé ensemble de la bulle individuelle,
et bien cette bulle devient collective quand on réunit un groupe à un endroit.
Quand vous prenez une commande ou quand vous servez ou quand vous desservez, vous percez cette bulle,
mais c'est tout à fait admis puisque c'est votre fonction mais comme vous percez la bulle,
je vous recommande d'identifier rapidement qui est le leader de la table.
C'est la personne qui rit le plus fort, c'est la personne qui en général fait des blagues, vous taquine,
mais c'est aussi la personne qui commande le vin ou qui prend les grandes décisions à table.
Et bien ce n'est pas forcément cette personne qui va vous mettre le pourboire
mais c'est la personne qui pourrait empêcher les autres de mettre un pourboire, en disant :
"Bah non, c'est pas la peine."
Donc il faut vous la mettre dans votre poche.
Pour ça, c'est très simple, il suffit de l'identifier, de pas trop en faire non plus. Il suffit juste d'une petite mise en avant,
d'une flatterie bien placée,
pour se mettre cette personne là dans la poche.
Il faut que ce soit fait intelligemment, c'est à dire,
ne flattez pas quelque chose qui n’existe pas.
Mais trouvez quelque chose d'appreciable chez la personne,
dans sa manière de vous parler ou dans sa manière d'être,
ou dans ce que cette personne là a choisi.
Mais encore une fois sans trop en faire.
La 3ème astuce est toute simple elle vient de la 1ère.
Quand vous allez amener les plats,
ne demandez pas pour qui c'est; mettez directement aux bonnes personnes
puisque vous aurez retenu en prenant la commande,
vous aurez fait ce petit effort mental temporaire,
et vous serez capable de donner les plats
sans redemander qui avait pris quoi.
Je vous assure que dans votre relation avec la table
ça vous fait marquer encore une fois beaucoup de points.
4ème astuce c'est quand on vous demande la note,
vous allez ramenez la note, ça c'est tout à fait normal
mais j'ai un vrai truc qui va mettre un grand coup d’accélérateur
sur le fait que vous allez avoir un bon pourboire.
Vous allez préparer à l'avance, chez vous, des petits cartons
alors ça peut être sur des cartes de visite blanches,
ça peut être au dos des cartes de visite du restaurant si le restaurant a des cartes
avec un dos blanc : c'est même d'ailleurs ce qu'il y a de mieux pour le faire.
Vous allez donc mettre avec la note un petit mot de votre part,
qui va inclure votre prénom et le fait de remercier la table.
Ca peut être simplement :
"J’espère que vous avez passé un bon et agréable repas,
à bientôt, votre serveur, Fabien."
Si vous ne vous appelez pas Fabien, mettez votre prénom..
c'est mieux.
Et avec cette petite carte et ce petit mot,
mettez aussi un ou deux bonbons.
LES BONBONS C'EST LA VIE !
LES BONBONS C'EST L'ARME ULTIME !
Si le restaurant ne fourni pas de bonbons gratuits,
vous allez acheter des gros sacs de bonbons à pas très cher
et vous en mettez juste un ou deux.
C'est une attention qui fait plaisir.
Qui vous rendra vous sympathique puisque c'est vous qui allez donner ça.
Y'a un restaurant où j'ai travaillé, y'avait pas les cartes de visite,
y'avait pas les bonbons, y'avait rien
on mettait juste la note comme ça en vrac sur la table.
Donc moi je prenais une sous-tasse, je mettais la note, le petit mot que j'avais prévu,
les deux petits bonbons et je posais ça sur la table.
Vous êtes en train de générer le tunnel idéal pour avoir un pourboire.
D'ailleurs dans ces cas là quand vous n'avez pas de pourboire,
c'est bien souvent parce que les gens n'ont pas de monnaie. Tout simplement.
Et c'est là que la 5ème astuce arrive.
Si quelqu’un vous paye avec un billet de 20€,
ne rendez jamais la monnaie sous forme de billets.
Si par exemple vous devez rendre 10€ et 20 centimes,
ne mettez pas un billet de 10€ et 20 centimes.
Mettez un billet de 5, deux pièces de 2, une pièce de 1 et 20 centimes.
Vous devez créer la monnaie qu'on sera susceptible de vous laisser.
Vraiment à chaque fois que j'ai fais ça,
même si je devais rendre 21€ je mettais pas un billet de 20 et une pièce de 1
je mettais un billet de 10, un billet de 5, et trois fois 2€
ce qui fais qu'à chaque fois on laisse une ou deux pièces au serveur.
Et avec tout ça vous allez voir votre taux de pourboire augmenter.
J’espère que toutes ces astuces vont vous servir cet été ou dans le cours de l'année
ou peut-être même juste là, actuellement,
ou dans quelques années.
Mais c'est du testé et éprouvé par moi,
et un mentaliste en serveur je peux te dire que ça réfléchit à tout !
J’espère que cette vidéo vous a plu si c'est le cas
n'hésitez à me le faire savoir en laissant en guise de pourboire un petit POUCE EN L'AIR,
vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo puisque je lis vraiment tous vos commentaires, chaque jour.
Un grand merci également à tous ceux et celles qui font les sous-titres,
qui écrivent les sous-titres pour les vidéos.
C'est un grand travail que vous faites (je confirme)
pour que les mal-entendants puissent accéder aux vidéos, merci beaucoup.
Si vous regardez une fois que j'ai validé les sous-titres maintenant
dans le descriptif de la vidéo on voit vos noms,
tout en bas pour vous mettre en avant parce que c'est bien normal.
Et abonnez vous bien sûr ! Puisque le mental vlog c'est une vidéo par jour
pendant un an ! Donc rendez-vous demain à 17h, ciao !